[Music]
in nature with us wow this is nice we
like to call this little tour the summer
of Pride this tour has everything hiking
community art lesbians lesbians making
art last year we gave saw shade Across
the Nation and celebrated Pride Across
the Nation with hundreds of you across
the nation this year we're back back
again with two new stops Atlanta GA why
because you're there in Salt Lake City
we're coming for you
of course this year all these fabulous
speakers will be coming from inside this
TV to a nature near you so come outside
and celebrate the beautiful LG HGTV
community
[Music]
it's pretty gay so there's no way this
is real is it this can be real